i look like a freaking i look like like
a who from whoville
what's up everyone i'm ninja and these
are my at home
10 essentials starting at number one is
going to be
my phone i know it sounds you know super
like cliche but i actually use this
every single day at home
because of what's been happening all
2020 i've been playing pokemon go
every day facetiming my friends and uh
just staying connected with everyone
do you have that feature on that lets
you know how much you've spent on your
phone
at the end of a week yeah i do it's bad
on average i was doing like 12 hours but
that was because i had pokemon go like
up and running so i don't know if it was
like because my face was in it
it was like your phone percentage or
your face time on your phone has
increased by 70
or so i was like oh
[Music]
my number two has got to be my
handy-dandy can of red bull
keeps me fueled and energized whenever
i'm doing crazy long grinds and streams
favorite red bull flavors in order the
number one is gonna be the coconut berry
number two is gonna be the tropical
which is like the yellow can
and then uh the regular is my third
favorite
coming in at number three finally got a
haircut like a couple weeks ago but
before that i didn't come out here for
an entire year
longest i've ever gone without a haircut
and the longest my hair's ever been and
i also discovered that i absolutely hate
when my hair is like falling in my face
and touching like the sides of my eyes
and stuff
so i had just purchased me a bunch of
hair bands so this is actually
a very very essential item
at home i've had the blue hair the
entire year and then also
just got it read blue so
we're staying blue
number four is going to be my red bull
bandana which also helps keep my hair
out of my face and also uh you know
just lets my stream and my my chat know
that we're on a nice
big long win streak when we're gaming
i have like 20 of these bad boys i have
a yellow one blue one white one
but whenever i win in like a battle
royale or any game that requires like
usually like a long win right so not
like a halo match where like if i win
the game because the human halo match in
like five minutes
uh so yeah it's kind of like an
indication that you know
you're coming into the stream hot
[Music]
number five is going to be my uh brand
new ninja hoodie that just came out
it's got dope little pieces on the side
which allow the sound to actually like
flow through so if you're wearing your
headphones over your hoodie if you're
super cold which by the way i'm always
freezing in my basement which is why my
hoodie is my number five essential item
always gonna have a hood on so i'm not
freezing
and also i can now put my headphones on
over my hoodie to stay even extra warm
[Music]
number six is going to be my sweatpants
these are
actually also my new adidas time and
sweatpants specifically that i'm showing
you
but just in general sweatpants i never
wear jeans
especially since i'm at home literally
all day every day
this entire year i think i've worn two
pairs of jeans this entire year
my relationship with adidas has been
absolutely fantastic the whole time in
and embrace the grind project has been
in the works for a long time
this actually is going to lead into my
next item which is number seven
which would be
the adidas ninja timing shoes now for
the pleasure of working with rick
williams who
started his own sneaker business out of
detroit you know i think a couple
decades ago almost
he has been on calls with me all the
time trying to figure out what i'm
passionate about and
really making these shoes and this glab
perfect and work really well
they're yellow you don't really see a
lot of yellow sneakers but the colors
are inspired from the chocobos from
final fantasy
you know every single pair of shoes the
exact colors are taken from
the colors of something that i
absolutely loved in video games growing
up
so you know it's pretty perfect
number eight is going to be my little
new
mouse that i started using it's the
logitech pro wireless just
i need my mouse to game all day and
you've always been
more pro pc gaming than console
controller gaming
no i used to be only console gaming back
in the day i'm halo was my first game
that i went professional in
or as a pro player and i just started to
adapt to the mouse
when i started grinding h1z1 the
transition was very difficult it was a
long process but i also spend like two
hours a day playing video games so
you know
coming in at number nine are gonna be my
sennheisers
i actually stopped using these recently
but i didn't want to unplug my other
pair of headphones which are my bare
dynamics
good sound quality i mean these are
these have great sound quality it's just
that like the way that
like my ears aren't that long and like
the holes are kind of long so
you know i just stopped using them but
headphones in general
need them every day
okay last but not least this specific
dog symbolizes that i need you know all
three of my dogs as my daily essential
items but this is cloud
and i just took him away from our entire
pack we rescued him
this year hey boy
he is now almost six months he is
super healthy he was underway when we
got him and now he's perfect
cloud comes from the final fantasy vii
main protagonist clouds of chowini which
means he's half
chihuahua half wiener dog aren't you
all right everyone that was my 10
at-home
essentials i hope you guys enjoyed the
video please like and subscribe and
have a great rest of your year